what you're looking for the best mobile
game to play what about raid Shadow
Legends what you've never heard of it no
raid Shadow Legends has awesome visuals
Lords of powerful Champions challenging
PVE bosses and tactical PVP content but
wait there's more today I'm going to
play a little game with you lot called
kiss Mari kill and with 750 Champions to
choose from this will be fun o Ana she
looks exciting let me tell you she's got
that half long hair half shaven head
thing going on which usually means they
crazy ah I would probably kiss her just
to keep her sweet it's not marriage
material Lydia she looks badass though
this one I'm a big fan of red on a woman
put her on pause I need to see what's
behind door number three h Tatu he is
grotesque there's no way I'm marrying
that he's minging he's getting killed
Lydia would get married I'd really I'd
marry the hell out of her and time is
running out for you to get the legendary
champion son Wukong for free by the way
he's absolutely brilliant in both PVP
and PVE so you don't want to miss out on
adding this prime prime mate you what I
did there to your Champion collection
simply log into your raid for seven
different days between now and October
23rd and you'll have this Monkey King at
your beckon call so click my link in the
description or scan the QR code and
you'll get a free starter pack with this
cool in-game loot if you're a new player
and you can play raid for free but for
now enjoy the
video he a Content ke do you know true
J you're going to decide that are you
what the is wrong with it you know
how they play I want to
[Applause]
out welcome back to the true Jordie
podcast today's guest is Bryce Hall
someone I wanted to get on for a while
you're here because of the Misfits card
Logan KSI Jake Paul and it's funny cuz
you're kind of the new generation of
that kind of crowd when I first seen you
I was say ah so this is the new version
of these guys bit different to them but
what's your relationship like with KSI
Logan and Jake specifically I feel like
with them specifically uh it's like one
of those where it's like we know each
other I think in the back of our heads
we respect each other I would say I
respect him but also it's like I'd fight
him really cool it's like I would fight
him you know and you're kind of like I
guess when I first seen you you you're
coming across like almost like little BR
to them like okay this guy's the come up
you weren't quite as far on with your
boxing as they were um what is your are
you closer to any of those guys than the
others um I mean I used to film videos
with Jake and Logan like when I was
coming up I went on impulsive and I I
did a few YouTube videos with Jake uh I
wouldn't say I was close with them yeah
at all it was just more like a hey we
had a lot of similarities very
controversial dudes on the come up
Spotlight doing like just stupid
for attention m have they any of those
dissed you at any point oh yeah they
they yeah they dissed me what was that
like for you then Logan dissed me at
this exact
table like he him and KSI dissed me at
this exact table oh FU oh yeah cuz they
filmed in my studio I remember that now
yeah and how did like if you don't mind
me asking what's that like though
because you're in the space with these
guys you're wanting respect to from them
were you just brushing it off or were
you like you never want to meet
your Idols really yeah it's like one of
those where it's like I didn't it didn't
like make me mad when I hear them like
on me it's more like oh man that
sucks like I looked up to these guys
when I was coming up I watched them
before I was really popping on social
media and then they're like on
me like I'm just like a
nobody who the hell is this kid let me
brush him off let me on him I had a
similar thing with Tyson Fury and Conor
McGregor um but uh in terms of the
actual card let's talk about the main
event KSI Underdog against Tommy Fury
seems very confident do you believe the
confidence I think anyone in like the
YouTube boxing space has to have some
sort of delusional
confidence um I do and you think it's
delusional oh yeah I mean yes 100% I I
give uh I give KSI props like he is
taking Tommy Fury over Jake Paul and I I
would say that Tommy Fury is a harder
fight he's taking like the the harder
fight versus the two and I don't know
why exactly maybe it's like some behind
the scenes like talk like okay if I if I
lose we'll set up a fight with Jake Paul
but uh I give him the props for for
fighting for how do you see that fight
going I don't see him winning I don't
see him winning at all I mean if he does
win I think it's going to be by like a
knockout yeah it's like going to be one
of those crazy overhand rights that he
always throws you see it more being like
Fury controlling him or stopping him I
mean even if you watch like Fury versus
Jake you saw the the difference between
like a real boxer and the best YouTube
boxer like there is
a humongous skill Gap like in a
humongous like where we cannot compete
with highle Fighters like any all the
YouTube boxers we we cannot compete with
these guys there are levels above us and
that's like what ksi's like main thing
is there's levels like there's there
actually is levels and we and we're no
we're nowhere near like levels to these
professionals we do this like as like a
a fun little thing and some of them are
kind of taking it too seriously and then
they're going to get a reality check
when they fight when you say too
seriously I'm assuming you mean their
belief in their belief in themselves
where they think that they're legitimate
Fighters right and in terms of Logan
Dylan you're actually quite poly with
Dylan right you're quite cool with him
yeah and what he's done is something
I've never seen in fight the fight game
like to go after someone's woman and
like to go after her religiously on a
daily basis what's your take on that
it's the fight game like you can say
whatever you want and it is up
but it's like you are trying to get into
your opponent's head you are trying to
do whatever possible to with them
get under their skin and then fight them
in a ring it's like a it's like a game
of chess
and to be honest like Dylan's winning
but then actually Logan's like now doing
like the okay I'm going to sue you right
I want to talk to you about that because
it's like a chess match and these guys
are good
yeah well the fight I mean yeah they
they're in this position for a reason
they know how to get under people's skin
both of them but the the fight Community
when Logan first started being attacked
in this way and his his misses was
brought into it a lot of pro Fighters
MMA guys are like you shouldn't be doing
this still and is way below the belt but
now weirdly it seems to be swinging a
little bit because of the lawsuit now
all those fighters who are seen saying
this is a shitty thing are now actually
saying but you shouldn't Sue him and I
seen a clip on Logan on Jake Paul's
podcast saying oh no like we can then
just take money from the rest of his
life now like we're going to and this is
going further and further and further
deeper I mean he's kind of now just like
flaunting that he has a lawsuit on Dylan
Dan do you think after the fight there's
going to be a moment where they shake
hands they laugh it off okay we'll leave
the lawsuit or do you think Logan's
going to be like let's say Logan wins by
knock out best best case scenario for
his side do you think he's just going to
be like and now I'm going to ruin your
life boy like or do you think
you'll leave it no I think he's gonna
he's he's playing that WWE villain in
real life now I think he's uh he's going
to just double down and just be like oh
yeah you're still piece piece of
now if I if Dylan
wins I think it's he's gonna like Logan
has to like kind of just be like okay I
got to retire from YouTube boxing it's
obviously not for me I'm still going to
sue you though yeah and how do you see
that fight going I I don't think um I
mean this in the most respectful way I I
don't think it's as mismatched as people
are putting it I think Logan's not that
great I don't think uh Dylan's we
haven't seen Dylan we've seen like clips
of him but like that's what he's putting
out for a reason he's a smart guy like I
think it's it's going to be a very good
fight I I I think the thing I'm
interested in seeing is Logan's sort of
weakness so far in his fight have been
like against KSI KSI had more the dog
right and that's what gave him that edge
I think Logan was probably the better
athlete maybe even slightly more
technically um more like a boxer and
then against Floyd like you can't be the
aggressor in that so this is the first
fight where I'm looking at him going oh
you got to be the aggressor here and
there's a real point to prove and it'll
just be interesting to see if he does go
out there and goes for the kill
immediately or if he is defensive and
looking the JB I I can't see him being
like a like the aggressor he is he is
like a a decent like he's an athlete
he's a decent he can move um maybe like
from what he's injecting like he'll
he'll have like that dog in him oh you
think so sure yeah really dude like come
on no I'm not the the thing is right cuz
you know in the UK right we don't have
the levels of athletes we see
religiously in America like when I watch
like high school sports in
America you guys are just jacked like
you guys are in the weight gym from 11
years old like it that isn't the UK like
we play sports once a week and we got a
lot of fat kids here so when I met Logan
I was like damn this guy is built you
know and like he's been built from 2018
since I first met him so I haven't
really seen that much of a change so in
my head I wasn't really thinking that he
is changing and he's getting more and
more in shape as he gets older when your
testosterone starts natur going down um
he's in the WWE where they promote
really jacked dudes like if you're an
average sized dude in the WWE on camera
at all times trying to act tough like
yeah I'm not saying it's it's not a
possibility it's just the weight gain
hasn't really been there it's more
defined I get that yeah he's getting
more defined he's getting more vascular
it's he's looking like he's just has he
looks like he has the testosterone of
like a high school boy do you think that
they'll go a few rounds or do you think
there'll be a stoppage I think people
want to see a stoppage but I don't see
it being stopped really I think it's
going to go to the distance Dyan is
tough though a he like that's the one
thing I'll give him yeah like you don't
got to be a blackbell I do not think
he's going to like get knocked out yeah
I think he's going to just keep moving
forward yeah I mean
personally I think Logan would be
disappointed if he doesn't get him out
of there like after everything that's
been said Logan doesn't win by knockout
he loses exactly I I agree I think that
would be a disappointment for him unless
it's like and humiliating playing with
your food type beating and Tommy Fury I
think Tommy Fury's going to do that like
where he's just going to play with KSI
really yeah that's the thing I think KSI
is going to have a better game plan Than
Jake in terms of like I think Jake tried
to outbox the boxer whereas I think KSI
is going to have the good game plan of
fight dog fight yeah and even if he
loses I think well what else what you
going to do like what what can you do if
if Ki doesn't get knocked out it's a win
yeah yeah I think think he's he's
fighting like a very skilled fighter and
like I said I respect that he's taking
that challenge upon himself after coming
back after taking what how how long was
that break like 3 years yeah yeah for
the music taking three year like a
threeyear break and then coming back and
only being active for another year and
then just taking like a a challenge like
that yeah my main worry is the kind of
Fighters he's been fighting have been
really below Tommy like you know what
Jake I think it's a conf a confidence
boost yeah but with Jake I was like okay
okay Tyron Woodley Anderson Silva like I
see the escalation here then Tommy Fury
so like when it wasn't going his way he
was able to cover up and make it hard
for Tommy to really hurt him and he
survived really well in those later
rounds whereas I don't think Jake uh JJ
has been put under the fire in the later
rounds and I'm just a bit worried like
even though it's only a six rounder are
you going to be experienced enough
against a puncher to if it didn't go in
your way like the first three rounds I'm
very confident that he'll have all the
energy and he'll be making it a dog
fight but if it turns and you're being
controlled you have to be able to look
after yourself in there right yeah I I
don't that's why I say it's like I give
him the props for accepting this fight
yeah like he he is he's fighting like a
real boxer and like a big dude as well
his opponents have been like absolute
dog water I
agree just like cat food he hasn't had
even a challenge since he came back
that's the worry is like you're going
from you know how like he's going from
pan Tommy fury like exactly like that's
that's where and that's where I'm kind
of putting a lot of pressure mentally on
his coaches cuz for you to give him bums
and then throw him in there with Tommy
Fury just a giant leap you must be
training him properly and you must have
good sparring because otherwise you're
letting him down if he goes in there and
gets absolutely toyed with well then
it's on his coaches because they're the
ones who said you're ready now yeah and
I wouldn't like to be them if it if it
does look bad you know what I mean on
your own event yeah yeah so what is it
that makes you want to fight then
because you're making money you don't
have to fight it's fun I I like uh
competition I'm a really competitive guy
yeah you a wrestler right yeah I was
yeah um and I think after taking like a
loss on my first fight it made me
stronger like it made me like I'm not
scared anymore I was I was like a scared
kid going in that ring against like you
know Austin McBroom and who who's a
legit athlete yeah yeah he is a legit
athlete um I did not take the training
seriously um I thought of it more of as
a game but like I hate losing and then
taking like a massive loss like that in
front of millions of people changed me
then I took like a win in front of like
that many people and I I just felt like
what a win felt like in front of that
many people and it's like oh man I want
to keep doing this I really appreciate
and respected the way you handled that
moment and like for me being a man is
about not getting caught up in your own
in that moment like so to not
let a loss Define you but also not let a
win Define you and when you held it
together in your win in that post match
speech and for those who don't know on
the runup to the first fight you've been
like I'm a fighter and you were talking
your I I was doing the McGregor did
the right thing you talked a lord of
got everyone interested I was
interested I hadn't really known about
you that much before and and I knew who
MC broom was and I was like this kid
really has got um Charisma and is
selling this brilliantly and when he did
lose I was like me cuz that breaks
some people but it didn't re break you
at all if anything it feels like it was
a blessing in disguise it it was it
really was um I even think like for like
when Logan lost against JJ uh it was
like a blessing for him
I think he after his loss became Logan
Paul I think after my loss I became
Bryce Hall like I think it was like the
same type of um taking a loss publicly
you can if you can handle a loss in
front of that many people publicly and
move forward you're really a winner yeah
that's that's being a man right and it
did feel like you went through a
transition from like boy to man within a
a few short months of like and I I
watched your first video last night that
you made after that where you had all
your mat roast in you and uh like Logan
did a similar thing he actually stole
that from me funny um but um it's
healthy to laugh at yourself and I think
that that gives you an edge over a lot
of these big time influencers you don't
have an issue with having a laugh at
yourself and that I think that'll always
keep you on the right side of the people
when people think you're above being
laughed at they don't like you anymore
and it it can be problematic for your
brand right yeah I think it's also
really easy to make fun of people
especially myself so I think it's like I
think it's like it's a good joke and
what is it you know when you're in the
gym I I look at some YouTube boxers and
I think some of you guys are trying to
prove something to your younger self or
some of you genuinely like Jake Paul I
think just likes hurting people like
some some people have that what what
where do you dig deep from what is the
thing that pushes you through your
workouts or or or makes you want to
knock someone out uh I just like getting
better um like like improving myself so
when I would watch Like My First clips
of me boxing and then seeing me now um
and as you train more and more
everything becomes like a muscle memory
like when when I was it kind of reminds
me like of my training when I was
wrestling where everything just became
like a muscle memory you wouldn't even
have to think about doing something it
would just happen so it's like I see a
punch thrown at me Instinct it's like oh
okay wow I have like an open shot right
here now boom like it it's just
something about learning getting better
and improving just makes me want it's
healthy for you right like I think
mental healthwise it's it's really
rewarding to feel that like oh I'm
improving like and when you achieve so
much at a young age and I think JJ has
spoken about this as well like you kind
of sort of lose your purpose at it
whereas this puts you right at the
bottom again right at the bottom
especially when you start off with a
loss so to feel that growth again it it
must be healthy for you yeah but you
wouldn't say you're a spiteful person no
you don't really love the hurting people
process no so what about MC broom then
so he's in your face and giving it all
of that how how bad was that in
internally like you know when you put
your head on your pillow at night before
you're about to fight this guy is it
fear is it aggression are you wanting to
hurt him the night before where are you
going with that that one was uh that one
was fear I think like also when I'm
stepping in the ring with somebody I
think of it more as like U like a
sparring match on a higher scale I don't
think of it as like I want to hurt this
person which I guess is why it makes
like I'm not a fighter like I'm just
like an Entertainer at the end of the
day um along with every other influencer
that's
boxing you you're sick of hearing that
right you're sick of hearing that yeah
like it's not nobody nobody's a boxer in
this influencer boxing space it's like
we're just what would it take for you to
accept them would it take for them to
beat a Tommy Fury see I would say that
Jake Paul is the only one that can claim
the boxer okay like where he's like okay
he's fought legitimate even though
they're not boxers he's fought
legitimate Fighters with legitimate
records and multiple like multiple
legitimate Fighters and have like
dropped them or knocked them out cold
like that's a that's a fighter I think
did you say the little thing that him
and Logan had on their podcast where
there was a bit of tension there yeah I
did what did you make of that uh I think
the competitiveness I think it was
always like a really known thing uh in
the influencer scene that Jake Paul was
actually like the good guy like
everybody everybody that knew Jake Paul
like in in real life he he's like a good
guy like Jake's a nice ass dude super
humble but then put on put on like the
front like of a villain right and Logan
was like the super nice guy online but
and then behind the scenes was like the
like the crazy one you know really is
that how you say cuz I I I mean that's
just like what everybody sees right I
personally don't know either of them
well enough to like give my opinion but
why B knuckle though of all the things
that you could have went off and done
I'm like bare knuckle like everyone I
knew was terrified for you even people
who didn't know you that well were like
this is crazy because in my head I'm
like you lost to Austin MC Brom Austin's
a solid influencer level boxer and the
guy I you were going to fight I know he
was smaller than you but he was hitting
PS and he I was like he's decent
him this is not a good idea he he had a
I think he had 30 amateur fights like he
he was like a legitimate uh Fighter for
sure what was the thought process in
taking B let's start with b and knuckle
especially took two years off after my
loss were you training that whole time
no not at all not at all I I didn't even
I think I put the gloves on maybe like
four times in two years wow but then uh
I started
training three and a half months before
my fight like before the bare knuckle
fight and after about like two weeks of
like putting the the gloves back on and
feeling like what it felt like again I
was like man I want to fight and I saw
like these clips on Tik Tok and like
Instagram reels of like Mike Perry and
like all these crazy just
doing bare knuckle uh hitting each other
in the face like getting dropped
breaking their face and I was like I
told I told my manager I said I kind of
want to try this with an influencer I
want I want to see if like any
influencer's down to do this with me and
we reached out to Dave Feldman and he
was like okay yeah we love it let's do
it we tried to reach out to like some
influencers none of them were down and
then I was like okay it just give
me give me give me a bare knuckle
fighter they're like are you sure and I
was like okay let's make it fair make it
like a guy that's like a lightweight
that has to come up and meet me at my
weight so I was 195 when I signed the
contract he was 135 and we both met at
165 so it was like uh okay this this
guy's The Experience he's he's really
good at fighting he's an undef
undefeated bare knuckle fighter I'm an 0
in-one amateur boxer he should have
still won yeah yeah but it was more like
I okay so the reason I did it it was
like okay I'm not scared to do this
let's like like let me show you
people like let me show the public I'm
not scared to do this type of um
and if I lost everyone was already
expecting it it's like okay I lost to a
a professional fighter cool like I
already lost my first one against like a
dad like who who's expecting me to win
this and then if I won which happened it
shocks the world and you did win and as
much as I was joking on in my reaction
to it
because you were clearly not as skilled
as him you your natural reflexes in
there were pretty good like you and the
fact that you went in the first 10
seconds and put it on him that showed
you w scared and you landed and knocked
him down what tell me that feeling of
like holy I just knocked down the
bare knuckle guy so my my game plan in
that fight most bare knuckle Fighters
like they stand in the middle and they
exchange that was not my game plan I'm
not trying to up my face I'm trying
to like you're in the wrong game yeah
I'm not trying I'm not trying to just
sit there bang with a another person in
the middle of a ring my my game plan was
to move around the ring and the
experienced fighter his house this
undefeated fighter has to has to prove
himself like he's like this guy's
challenging me a Tik tocker is
challenging me I'm gonna I'm going to
beat the out of him so I was
waiting for him my game plan was to move
around wait for him to come into my
range and in the first 10 seconds he did
and that's what that's what my game plan
was it's like okay as soon as he's in my
range I'm going to I'm going to give him
like a a really like nice punch and what
was it like feeling the bare Knuckles
touching the face like that cuz
obviously you can't really train for
that you around and find out what
it is in the ring right like yeah was it
much different to full on boxing gloves
like after the first round it was I was
feeling everything but like my
adrenaline was pumping so much in that
first round where I would get hit my
vision would almost like like it would
uh flash I hear you it would flash it
wasn't hurting but it was like every
time I got hit right here it was like
it's like the movie it's like I blinked
I was like huh oh I'm in a different
spot now that's kind of weird but yeah I
was it's like it didn't hurt until like
the second round when he when he clipped
me across my like cheek and like or it
was like my eyebrow where he split my
eyebrow open I felt that like it
was you you kind of see me like when he
hits me with that and then I start like
dripping in blood it felt like a like a
knife just like stabbed me right in my
eye like that's what it felt like and I
was like oh my god did he just
hit me with his hand like that like and
I kept like a straight face I kept like
a straight face like like that was easy
like sit back and I just saw the Blood
start to pour out I was like oh my God
he cut me all right I have four
more three more rounds of this all
right I can I could probably survive
yeah it's not what you signed up for in
a way though yeah like I'm here to be
up and give it everything and and
find out what I'm about and the one
thing in both of the fights that you've
had despite being outmatched you showed
heart and you got a chin like you've
definitely got it like in that Austin MC
broom fight you had no business being in
there with him and yet you were just
admirable man like I swear to
God like I remember thinking if he
learns how to box he has the the what's
inside to push him to that next level
and I think you showed a hint of that in
the bay knuckle thing obviously the
fight was cut short by injury
but you proved your point in what we've
seen and in that post match speech where
you you made that like when you said
I've always been a fighter I love that
because it showed like ironic humor in a
in a moment where you should be going
crazy I told you so like ksi's been
saying all week if he wins it's going to
be over for everyone like they'll never
but you kind of kept it together in in a
more likable way than that maybe like
and how did you find the the presence of
your mind to be able to not go crazy and
to be able to go you actually said look
I got a B look he you know he's a great
fighter he cracked this you were very
level-headed why um to be honest like I
I I'm humble in defeat and humble in
Victory uh I I don't like the the guys
that that'll win a fight and then just
act like they're the like nobody
can take them because it's like anything
can happen in any of these fights m i
don't want people to go back and be like
oh look at how cocky this guy was and
then I lose another fight you know yeah
like I'm humble in Victory and I'm
humble in defeat like I I'm going to go
in there I'm going to I'm going to beat
deji's ass and then I'm going to shake
his hand and be like hey you're a good
fighter and I don't want him to quit I
want him to keep going I respect that
there must have been a moment though
like I don't know let's say and I kind
of want to know what that was like where
you realized I just want a bare
knuckle fight in front of everyone who
doubted me like whether it was when you
got home what was that little moment it
was it's like I would joke along with it
but it's like people would just go like
hey look I'm not a fighter I'm not a
boxer H look you lost to your fight and
lose so it was like I kept hearing that
constantly and I'm just like man I need
to do a new I need to do another one
yeah like I need to do another one like
I I was like thinking like maybe do I
retire here but it was like no I'm
still young like I want to fight
like it's fun and then I was just like
okay what can get the people going like
this guy's insane he should try this and
I I that people talking about you
how does that impact you because we all
get it it's never been hard for me uh it
it's like it's so weird to say but I've
been bullied like my entire life growing
up it was it was like very it was
affecting me like immensely when I was a
kid how old were you s like when I was
12 to 17 yeah they rough years so like
yeah like the the high school like you
think you think school is life like you
think these are the only people you're
ever going to know and then once you
leave High School you realize how stupid
all of it was that's kind of like how I
think and view life as I think I'm in
one big high school and people are
talking about me just like I was in
high school and none of their opinions
really matter I know who I am at the end
of the day like I I don't care what
people say about me so it's healthy to
be in that place and it it's hard to
have you kind of have to find a balance
of like all right I I want to
acknowledge the opinion but I don't want
it to become everything you know what I
mean like yeah take a bit of feedback
but not let it Define me and like you
say you've got fight with deji coming up
and why why deji specifically I think he
is he's one of the best influencer
boxers yeah I think he's probably more
technical than KSI his record does not
reflect on his skill level at all you
know why that is is cuz he just didn't
dedicate he do he doesn't have the dog
like KSI does if KSI had deji's
technical boxing skill and had the ego
that he has and the dog that he has he
would be he could actually probably be
like a a really good professional B I
know a m man who trains with pros and he
knows a pro who spots deji and says he
is good like no off camera he
is good so it it is it is a difficult
fight from someone looking from the
outside in for you because I believe
you're the better athlete I believe
you're probably more tenacious and
you're bigger and probably stronger but
he has got like a bit of silky skill to
him where he will leave his chin out on
a plate and wh and now you say his now
and then come back count to you yeah but
I'm not like a fousy tube athlete like
fousy tube's like a jack dude and he was
he was in there with deji when he
shouldn't have been and he he's slow
like I'm I'm like a fast big dude like
I'm I'm not like a like a 165 that moves
like I'm like 190 like I'm a 190 that
moves like I'm 145 I agree that's how
you caught your guy in bare knuckle if
he put if if that deji that fought fousy
tube fought me to tomorrow I would I
would put him to sleep I like that I'll
clip that
up and and and I think if I was you I'd
be looking at deji thinking I need to
put you in a competition of who wants it
more and who's going to work harder like
there's always just been that question
mark of Dei as is he going to be in
shape and I think he's definitely gotten
better at that but it's still there in
the back of the head and I think that
would be the type of fight you'd want to
create I guess yeah and I I think I
think he would take me seriously I think
deji knows that I would 100% be his
hardest fight to date agreed um he
hasn't fought anyone like super serious
besides Floyd Mayweather obviously
but when you say that besides the Floyd
Mayweather Floy Floyd definitely took
him lightly I think Floyd gave him the
nicest treatment that he gave like cuz
Floyd treats people with disrespect but
for whatever reason I think he kind of
liked deji and he was like okay as I've
seen him humiliate other guys like high
level Bo and I think he wanted to hurt
Logan bad actually I don't think he
wanted to hurt too big yeah I don't
think he wanted to hurt deji in the same
way and de you actually gave him that
black eye right so you know if you can
land on Floyd you can land on you so
that's another thing for you to Bear
mind I guess and I think uh this is this
is what I will say about deji I think he
is uh like he's not like KSI he's he
doesn't have that dog and and I think
he's really weak-minded uh and he gets
easily demotivated and that that's why
he sometimes doesn't come into shape
with like some of his fights I think
he's going to hit me with his hardest
punches and he's going to realize that
I'm not going to go down and that's
going to destroy him mentally and I'm
going to keep moving forward and I'm
going to keep hitting him harder and
he's going to have to like like oh
I'm gonna lose to another tick tocker
those bastard ticktockers those bastard
ticktockers take that knee oh God
remember that that was one of the
funniest boxing matches ever credited
deji he he's got he was comedic in that
but he has one interesting thing you
know since he started winning again
there's there's been a kind of
consistent thing that happens where in
the fights where he lost he kind of
talked a load of and then didn't
show up and I've noticed when people
like foozy are in his face giving it
that and he's like okay and he does this
thing where he just doesn't react how do
you think you're going to handle the
runup to the fight with him are you
going to be trying to drag him out into
a war of words or are you just going to
let him be the the Silent Assassin there
I mean it it's like can try to be the
Silent Assassin you know like I don't
there's there's no fear going in with
deji like there's not a there's not like
oh like he might whoop my ass like
I don't think like that I also don't
think he has what it takes to embarrass
me I think he is like a very highly
skilled influencer
boxer but that's it are you still
training regularly now you are you on
the runup now yeah no I'm still training
four times a week and have you got a s
say a coach MH yeah I'm training with
George Foreman Jr right now I'm training
four times a week I'm like obviously on
this vacation like two time or uh I'm
going to try to train with Edris oh
Virgo yeah Virgo we're actually damming
right now I want to I want to spar him I
want to because I know he's like I know
he's KSI is like main sparring partner
so I wanna I want to see like I'm gonna
tell him yo Spar me like you Spar KSI
and I want to see these levels that KSI
talks
about the bolds on this guy I love it I
love it and I I mean I think Idis is
like extremely talented he is good yeah
cuz he beat um you know the guy on the
last one um Aaron Chas yeah and and Chas
you know you see him with Floyd Floyd
wasn't treating him like he deji yeah he
he he realized I got to be on my game
here just to make sure I I I I look as
good as I want to look it's not just an
easy you know let's go for a jog typees
pace
so yeah Idris was calling me out on
Twitter one time like he wanted to fight
me I was like dog what are you shut up I
must admit the thing about that guy that
I I will say that it doesn't sit right
with me is like you're you're not an
influencer boxer he's levels above all
of these infl yeah you're like Tommy
you're Tommy you're like I F Tommy I I
can't be bothered to fight these Pros
for like less than money than what I'm
going to get for beating up these
influencers to let me up these but
I think Misfits are going to have to be
very careful with who they match him up
with you know cuz it's it can be
dangerous putting him in there with like
if he put him in there with you that
wouldn't be a fight but but what you
want to put yourself in there with them
to find this out are you worried that
they'll be sharing information taking
about the deji and all you just like
it I mean like I'm not going to be
like the same fighter tomorrow like when
when I spar with Idris I'm not going to
be the same fighter that fights Dei also
I don't think
anyone has seen me box recently they
they they saw me brawl with with uh G
Perez but they didn't see me box and I
am a completely different boxer now I
agree I agree yeah you you were and I
say this respectfully you weren't ready
you were a baby you know you learning
learning on the job in a main event it's
never a good idea all of those eyeballs
yeah and and that's what I try and put
across to people who slug YouTube cuz I
hang around with real boxers and I'm
like well your debut was in front of
what 200 people in a boxing club like
they do it in front of 20,000 people
it's not really fair on them they're
learning in front of the eyes of the
world right and that's why I give you
all the credit to do that and I think
when you do fight deji that is going to
be a sick event you pick well in that
regard and there's other fight as who
you might fight I think werson Nunes
might be a good fight for you one day
that's why I'm like looking at you know
someone like Ryan Taylor that people are
like yo you should fight Ryan Taylor
where I'm like dude I would walk through
that guy and make it look like it was
super easy really interesting like I
would make it look so easy have you seen
the Bad Blood between him and swams uh
where swams goes where's that kid
where's your kid also he also talks
about me not not swarms I think
swarms is a really nice guy but like
Ryan Taylor he like will will say like
oh it's on site when I see you I'm just
like okay Ryan's wild that's that's the
one thing I'm I'm a believer of like he
it it would be onite if he said it like
I mean I'm going to see him so well
we'll find out then right yeah we'll see
um when I was looking you up I I seen
that you done a movie with 50 Cent yes I
did that's cool bro I was
actually like fight KSI uh when he was
doing his like comeback oh really yeah
um but I was in the middle of shooting
my movie with 50 Cent oh sorry sorry
just busy 50 Cent y dude can you wait
like a month I'll be done yeah I love 50
Cent mate what was it like doing that
movie with it dude he's a he's a lot
bigger in person like that guy is like
really sick but yeah the movie should be
coming out um I think February so like
around when I fight yeah what kind of
role do you play kind of like
a douche but like also like a a nice
douche like hey like this guy method
then right yeah yeah I was I was
literally just playing
myself um it was uh really sick to work
with 50 Cent um really nice dude
actually you'd be surprised he's been
through so much in his life mate yeah
like like when you look at what
he's built it makes all these YouTubers
going I came from nothing it's like no
no you you came from a nice house and
you had a nice computer with nice
cameras and all that 50 Cent like that
was nothing in terms of Hollywood
obviously there's parties there's girls
it's got us upsides you done much of the
old Hollywood partying since you become
famous yeah I I've the face on him the
face on he's like yeah no bro like
I was I 17 doing that really I'm
over it now yeah level up I kind of like
grew it how old are you now 24 wow to
say you're over it at 24 is wild yeah I
know I'm like over the partying cuz I
partied so hard like when I was
like 17 to 22 how bad we talking what
what kind of levels there's levels to
this there's levels to party what level
let me tell you guys there's levels to
party none of these influencer boxers
are on my
partying they're not I believe it I
believe it what we saying like what dud
like 30 naked girls in our pool like it
it was like that type of like the the
movie type parties we were doing those
and I got I don't know if I like what I
can say and what I can't say so it's
like just know that they were
parties you're an extremist type of guy
right like you you you didn't get into
being famous cuz you wanted to be a
normal dude like you obviously have that
attraction to excitement um what was the
the reason behind you wanting to be
famous mainly because I didn't have
friends so I I started with live
streaming on YouNow uh which was like a
competitor with twitch so I started
because I didn't have anybody to talk to
wow I sound like such a loser I
didn't have anybody to talk to so I was
just like yeah I was just like oh man I
want to talk to some people so I would
go live there'd be like three or four
people on my chat you go live on a
hashtag and it's like based off of views
so it's like you would go higher up in
ranks as more people would watch you um
and I remember like having like three or
four people in my live streams just
talking to me and I would like talk back
and then it just gradually kept growing
like at one point it got to when I was
14 years old 5 th000 concurrent viewers
which is great Jesus yeah just me
talking like me talking doing stupid
challenges pranking people jumping off
of it was just weird do you think
you were aware of 14 what why you were
doing that uh no I just saw the the
views and then I got my first paycheck
and I was like wait I don't have to
work at a grocery store how old
were you when you got your first one 14
can you remember how much you got paid
$2,500 that's a life moment right oh I
bought I spent it all in like I think a
weekend just on like clothes shoes cuz I
would just my mom would buy me all my
clothes so I'm like all right let me get
my whole wardrobe changed that must be
challenging for for your mother because
she's obviously trying to get you
educated and get you a job and to do the
right thing and all of a sudden you're
getting drawn off into this was she
worried no she believed in me she
believed in me from day one and that's
why uh she's my number one supporter and
I love her yeah I rate that um if I'm
right thinking you are single mother
family just like me um I think both our
dad's in jail as well so we got just
yeah just got that in common um my dad's
out now so thank you I think mine is too
um but yeah I did a bit of reading up
and and your upbringing yeah it was not
the easiest right like emotionally and I
know you've talked a little bit about
about your dad where's where's your head
with that situation now because uh you
were very young when you stopped seeing
him and now you're going through a lot
lot of things where you're becoming a
grown man yourself now so you get a
different perspective right on viewing
his behavior has anything changed in the
way you view him in the way I view him I
still think he's a total piece of
and I never want to meet him has he
asked to meet you yeah uh I just so
growing up I would get bullied for not
having a father and my mom would always
like cry and say she is super sorry
about that but in my head it never
clicked where I was like I didn't
remember having a dad so it's like
didn't know what it was like to have
both parents mhm so I was like this is
just normal to have like a single mother
busting her ass off so like every time
someone would make fun of me and people
still sometimes like as a joke like will
make fun like you have no Dad where it's
like I don't even take offense to it
because i' never had a dad and I don't
know what it was like to have a dad from
personal experience when you watch your
mother struggle like that it makes you
fiercely loyal right like and I can
imagine now the way I'm I'm I've seen
little Clips here that how close you
guys are what does she think about you
doing Bay knuckle as well like cuz there
there's one thing being like well done
you're doing live streaming it's another
going mom I'm going to go and
get punched in the face she was she was
brick uh my uncle's like a
taekwondo Master he came um he did a few
MMA fights in his life was two and 0 and
retired because he felt bad for breaking
a dude's ribs wow yeah he came and he
was electrified he was like oh
this is sick uh my mom was
bricks understandable I told her I was
like just don't watch the fights leading
up cuz they're brutal I'm not going to
fight like that and then of course she
watched all the fights leading up and
she's there sitting front row watching
girls and guys get their teeth knocked
out Jes did you see that clip recently
that chick's mouth wow she looked like
she went to the dentist and then some
right was bad it was bad like that those
types of fights are just so bad and my
mom thought my fight was going to be
like that so she's freaking out all my
friends are also freaking out like I
brought some of my friends out there um
and they're like getting super worried
my friends that don't even drink they're
getting super drunk like they're like oh
God we got to be hammered before this
hammered for
this yes obviously she was super nervous
and uh once I won wanted to find her
make sure I was like super like wanted
to let her know I was good I had like a
scar on my eye so I was just like no
this is all I got it's awesome yeah and
with your mother I'm assum uming you
financially have removed those burdens
now what did that feel like bro um I
started social media um like when I
started making money I told her my goal
was when I started to buy her a house so
as I was actually shooting the movie
with 50 Cent um in the middle of my
scenes I was signing papers for her
house in Florida that I bought amazing
so I was like oh wow this is what it
what it kind of feels like
to like what's my new goal like yeah
like that was that was the reason I
started so it's like now I'm like okay
so I guess I
can help other people or help like
should I get myself some now like
I'm good right what was her reaction
like when you got that bald her
eyes out just felt good not for her to
cry not for her to cry no but that's
what it's about right you know you you
did good for her yeah I think that's
such a good part of your story that I
don't know I know some people know about
it but it's great that you put that out
there
because I don't know I think not enough
influencers focus on the backstory as
well and and you mentioned about your
dad you said you never want to meet him
he reached out why was it a flat no and
would you ever reconsider uh abuse so he
was an abusive person right um didn't
want
to he's a he was my mom obviously I
don't know but like my mom's telling me
he's like a mooch so he will probably
just try to be like oh a man I'm
struggling yeah never paid child support
so maybe once he pays that back yeah
it's funny how many famous dudes like
Eminem Joe Rogan their their dads come
crawling out of the wood I've seen like
this video like once they start getting
ATT it's like oh hey I missed
you that's crazy I missed you just like
me the other seven I don't care about
them but you you're so sick yeah it's a
bad look that right like you yeah a
little too late bro so we talked about
the the most important lady in your life
what about the the ladies the women the
females uh what's describe your love
life so far you're 24 years old so
obviously you know uh no love life as of
right now I had I had that like my
girlfriend in the past yeah the famous
chick right yeah the famous chick uh
this is what I realized when I look for
a girlfriend and when I'm like actively
trying to find a girl that I want to
date it never works out like I'll find
like a a girl that I'll just want to do
like a one night stand totally fine with
that but it that that's not like my
girlfriend yeah when I find a girl that
I think I'm going to date it takes me
like three four months to have sex with
that girl no if I have a if I have a
girl that I like genuinely like I will
not have sex with her for like 3 4
months wow that's that's insane
self-control by the way is what's the
reason cuz sometimes like sex will just
distract you from like actual feelings
with your significant I think the sex
kind of like amplifies your feelings and
you don't you don't really recognize a
person you're you're falling in love
with uh the sex I be the like so like
you actually only like the sex you don't
like the person so if I like the person
I want to I want to know if I actually
like the person I don't think sex is as
intimate uh or important as actually
finding a soulmate deep that for a
guy your age with all due respect that's
you know you've got it figured out cuz
like I've been in relationships before
or or things before where it's been like
a few months goes by and I'm like God
you're actually a yeah like I just
love the ass like what that I don't love
you like they saying and and obviously
like you're kind of Sid stepping that
problem by really figuring that out but
then what do you do if they throw it at
you on night and you're like no like and
all of a sudden it's like get off me you
what I mean stop stop it no dude stop
putting that ass how do you deal like I
don't know I mean like I I tell them
straight up so if it's like if I do not
have sex with a girl on the first day um
it's like I'll tell the girl straight up
I'm like hey I don't I don't do this I'm
like I want to see like what this is
first but it's like yeah I'll have those
one nights where it's like I'm after
it's like after a club I'm drunk met you
at a club like that type of vibe it's
like all right goes down how do they
react though when when you say I'm not
that kind of guy wow I didn't expect
that and then they like I bet you they
love it I bet you they love it and then
you become the challenge oh M you've got
it all figured out this guy's a genius
is there a type that you have physically
and mentally uh no type it's like
obviously it's a bonus if the chick has
like a dump ass you know what I mean
like if she has like a fat old boond
that's awesome that's like uh a physical
feature but like yeah there's no
physical attributes besides like the
Bunda okay so personality wise what
personality I just like I like a girl
that has drive like she has a plan uh
with her future like she's not just a
like a oh I just want you to buy me
things okay yeah yeah I like a girl that
has her own drive and obviously I'm
gonna buy you things if you're my girl
right yeah but I don't like the girl
that immediately makes that the yeah the
trophy wife type you want more like what
what you doing with your life you know
yeah and like how are we then on a
journey together rather than yeah I I
would also want a girl uh that'll
that'll be in my my content all right
yeah yeah yeah she has to be kind of
cool with that like just maybe not like
uh like always in my content but if the
camera's on and like you're here it's
like it doesn't matter yeah I I wondered
if the Logan Paul experience had had
made you rethink that because when he
put his girl in the content she then
became available for shots right like
and and is there a worry that you have
to then protect that woman from the the
outside world a little bit um I noticed
like with every single girl that I'm
with or I'm talking with like they they
always talk about like hate that they
get and like it bothers them but I I try
to explain in the best way possible that
like they shouldn't worry about it
because it's like pointless who the
are these people to talk about you
you know you yeah like it's kind of like
my motto where I'm like hey this is how
I view it but they're
not as I don't know no they're just
different right like one thing mom's
Taylor said on the last podcast was
different things make people depressed
like we can't have our expectations of
what we're okay with on the next person
and I really felt that I was like yeah
like and you and I have been built and
trained over years to get used to this
and you're kind of they're not getting
that graduation they're just getting
dropped in the deep end like hey
you ready we're on the intern
yeah expect this millions of people are
going to start on you by the
way good luck yeah no so I guess you
have to be
really it's if it's a girl that's
already in the space it'd be easier but
if it's like somebody that's like
completely new to it and then I'm like
you said dropping them right into the
deep end and then saying good luck
that's harder let's say nobody knew her
body count but it was high would that
bother you it depends like just how high
like I mean I 25 I don't think that's
high for a female yeah I think
especially in our day and age too
yeah in La I assume like in LA too like
I think uh if it's higher than mine I'd
be like
okay hey let's chill chill out there dog
let's chill out but you never know I
mean we'll see at what time at what age
in your life do you see being the right
time for you to go you know what I'm
going to I'm going to settle down now do
you think it would be later closer to 30
yeah yeah closer to 30 when I'm like
okay I think with in the next two girls
and it could even be my next girl uh
that that's going to be the woman I
marry wow I haven't dated you know like
I had like my last girlfriend was two
years ago or three damn it's been three
three years you're doing a lot of
growing right now right so like you're
probably feeling more mentally ready now
yeah think I think when I was in my last
relationship I was definitely not ready
for a relationship yeah and do you think
she was or yeah I think she was the
she's she's the relationship type like
she's the she's like the wife you you
know like she's like a like I could I
could get married tomorrow type girl I
feel like men shouldn't even think about
marriage until they're 30 cuz where're
we're as much as we growing up
we're immature imature yeah yeah women
are more configured to it than what we
are and also like you kind of want to be
at the peak of your powers for when
you're making a decision like that in
the in the best possible situation that
you can be in so that you're not like
you don't want to regret it later and I
I I know a few dudes who get married in
their mid to early 20s and like you see
them at 30 and like shit's changed from
like they're two different people and
it's like why did you do that then you
know um well when you think you know you
know right yeah it it it's funny cuz
there's this theory about men being like
taxis and once the light comes on
they're ready and for you to just say
that and be like I think it'll be the
next one or the one after I don't know
something must be changing for you I
mean I would think because just because
I know how serious I would take a
relationship
like I'm not going to date a girl unless
I think that that's the girl yeah and
you so you've had casual flings I did a
little bit of uh research Tana T we were
never a thing did you ever yeah we
right but not like a there was
never like a we were talking why why do
you a girl like Tana what's the
sort of thought process I mean I was
like 18 19 um I mean that'll do
it she's alive I was 18 19
we were both drunk uh we were at a party
just kind of happened yeah cuz she's
talked about it a little bit on a
podcast and I just thought that was an
interesting one because she's
controversial right like she knows how
to extremely she stays relevant for for
however she somehow gets involved in
every single little drama even if it's
the farthest thing from her yeah that
would terrify me being involved with a
woman like that i' be like oh like
you say
1819 our I think our entire sexual
experience
um that one time that we had sex is just
out to the public they know from the
minute we laid in bed to like in
excruciating detail oh God to when we
left is that a worry for you in terms of
like cuz you know normal guys is your
age right we're going to have moments
where we turn up and we're pissed off
off with face and we we we take a girl
back and we just sexually don't perform
for example but with you you're like I'm
a I'm a story to and and it
ain't even necessarily like a social
media Sor like you're just some bar talk
where oh yeah she Bryce Hall last
week and this and like every detail is
out there are you conscious of that or
do you try and ah it I try to
perform as best as possible every single
time so that that story he's like he was
great that be knuckle guy wow dude oh my
God talk about bare knuckle yeah fist he
just got the fist out just went straight
for the anal passage unbelievable
I mean that's a new one
but because I don't know for for men
like I usually at that age it's kind of
like it depends what's in front of you
cuz sometime women women I think
sometimes have this impression like if
he was bad in bed with me he's just bad
in bed with everyone they don't realize
it we we perform levels there's levels
there's levels to sex and I raise my
game for whatever's on the table depends
the girl if the girl doesn't match the
right energy it's not going to be like
the best sex I've had some girls where
it's like wow the sexual energy and like
I was saying like the sex like you fall
in love with the sex and not the person
like the sex is so good where it's like
oh my God I think that I could
marry this this is so insane the energy
just matched like you guys like are so
perfect for each other just in that you
guys match the vibe like it's just kind
of flowing like an ocean like it's it's
insane like those types of girls and
then you'll find the ones where it's
like you'll you'll fall in love with
their personality and then the sex is
like
wow wow that was that was so good yeah
yeah that was amaz that was amazing that
was the best two minutes of my life but
but then it's a cliche but like the
crazy are the best sex and and
the the sex will be crazy but the
arguments will be even crazier oh yeah
and that's when you kind of have to go a
this good this is good but it's not that
good yeah it's the it's the mainly the
Latinos I've noticed mate Latinos are
beautiful yeah but they are all so crazy
crazy good in bed too he likes the big
asses the Latina's come naturally right
yeah I've been I've been going back and
forth with this uh this Latina like
fling she's Argentinian oh sounds
amazing yeah and she's she's got a giant
giant
butt I love the honesty L be honest
shout out M amazing yeah we love it yeah
we'll see we'll see where that goes yeah
levels yeah there's been levels there's
levels to this we rate it me
honestly I rate the honesty because not
like what you're saying is so true about
like falling in love for the sex and I
think as men we are so easily duped into
that and one day you wake up and it's
like it is actually other than the
sex I had a moment where I was like how
do I get this girl out of my flat right
now like she's going she's just
screaming and going crazy and I I I've
been in a situation before with a chick
where I was literally like you're so
crazy I'm scared to ask you to leave cuz
I feel like if I even just if I even
just suggest that I feel like I'll be
reported for something like she's just
crazy do you know what I mean like and
as when you got a bit of profile as a
guy you're like I don't want to my
life up just for this crazy but
I'm might like I'm scared of you right
now and it is a different level of like
power when you're a man where you've got
something to lose and that scenario cuz
you don't want to piss these girls off
but yeah we keep going back to the Latin
that's unfortunately yeah it keeps
happening um you said on a podcast
recently you tried
mushrooms and I've never tried them
before but I've heard that they give you
some real good perspectives on life and
just uh better understand yourself and
where you're going and sort of thing so
what did you get from those experiences
I I micros uh not not as much I haven't
micros in a while it's been like
probably like two months since I took
mushrooms three months um
yeah something like that have you ever
done a a fuckload and yeah what was that
like the craziest experience
I've ever had in my life uh it's one
it's when I had like my my uh crazy turn
on on social media like a different
perspective of how long ago was this
what period of time after Austin MC yeah
yeah yeah 2022 okay 2022 I took
probably I would say I didn't measure it
obviously but probably close to like 10
gram of
mushrooms so I Ed I edit takes a lot of
mushrooms he just told me that's a lot
with a look
yeah like 10 grams of mushrooms it was
like a tripping seeing like I was I was
talking to myself not knowing I was
talking to myself like it was it was
like people were watching me that were
sober and they were like yo what the
are you doing um I cried looking at
stuff like it was that type of vibe like
I would I look at the sun uh like the
sun setting and I'd start balling my
eyes out like it was trip like I was
tripping but I had like this whole
Vision in my head um and if I tried to
explain it in words I
saw
the evil version of myself die and when
you say evil version what did it look
different the one the one that wanted
like the greedy one like there like my
my life was split into twos like I was
watching
like the version of myself now and the
version of myself like the my old self
and I like split and this version killed
this one it was so it's like it's so
hard to explain so the good version
killed the bad version yes and it it
felt good and I started crying from that
too because I thought I
died I was tripping bolts wow yeah but
uh and when you came
to was was any of those realizations
still with you did you take things
further on beyond that cuz you said you
changed your behavior on social media
after this um yeah what were those sort
of I think it was like the what what you
were explaining where I think a lot of
these these dudes need to just take
mushrooms when you say these dudes you
mean these influenc inflc boxers or
influencers in general I think uh they
they develop like such an ego and I can
say like for myself like I had it as
well uh they think they're better than
everybody else
um they they put themselves on a
pedestal think that they're not like a a
common human being um but everybody is
the exact same it's just some people
have uh better work ethic and some
people are just straight up Lucky yeah
that was a lot of those like
dude ticktockers everyone that
just did the Renegade got super famous
overnight yeah some took advantage some
didn't there's an attachment isn't there
that they they they seem to develop
where if becomes a part of who they are
they Place such importance on the
numbers that they do and and that's
where the the superiority complex comes
from I think of like I am this person
and these millions of people are sort of
almost belong to me and they worship me
and adore me and I am I'm like a god I
think I think uh KSI should take a bunch
of mushrooms KSI I will do I will
personally be your trip sitter and I
will take ton of mushrooms with you
and we can just go walk on a field and
see see what see what happens like I
really don't give a anyway about
followers and stuff like that but I want
to push myself further and this does
seem like a good way of doing that of
like realizing reality through being I
think I think what what I will say if
you're going to do it you need you need
somebody that's going to like guide you
through it because you're you're going
to have moments where you get scared
like very
scared um um if you take a lot like if
you're only micro doing if you're only
micro doing you you'll just feel like an
a more Amplified version of yourself uh
colors are more Vivid um you walk around
super happy like it's it's it's really
is that a dangerous though to get used
to that Happy State and and and being
out of your normal State no cuz I still
I like I have like I said I haven't done
it in three months and I still feel
great like I it's not an addictive drug
so it's it's left a permanent change
there you feel yes wow not saying for
the public to do it by the way not
encouraging the public to do it but from
my personal experience I've had a great
experience do you think that'll do you
think that'll help you with the defeat
to Austin specifically um no no uh I
think it was more it affected me more
with how I dealt with the backlash of it
oh okay like the the defeat itself like
losing losing a fight it's like I've
losing fights it's like oh man you're
stronger than me right like we're dudes
who cares
uh it was more the the people making fun
of me for it and I couldn't say anything
about it cuz it's like they don't know
what it was like they don't know what
it's like to step in front of millions
of people and fight like punch another
man in the face and get punched in the
face and experience that at like a 21y
old yeah it was just like all of that
just constantly getting reminded about
it there's this thing on social media a
mate of mine Chris uh Chris Williamson
said it said when you're on the come up
you you remind people of themselves
because they have dreams too but when
you achieve those dreams and I might be
butchering this but when you achieve the
dreams a lot of the people who are
watching you haven't achieved those
dreams so you then kind of remind them
of what they haven't done and that's
when they change towards you and that's
when they want you to fail and that's
when people start rooting for you and
then they they take great pleasure in
the down and let's not kid ourselves
like one of the main reasons why this
Prime card is going to sell so well is
because the four main guys all have so
many hate
like all of them and that's a weird
thing right like and and when you hit
the point that you've got with millions
of followers like half of those guys are
just they hope that you post something
oh I did this wrong or you know
what I mean yeah it's a weird I think
that's why like a lot of the live
streamers are blowing up right now it's
like watching like a potential train
wreck yeah like like uh like when fousey
was just reowing up every single
stream he was doing something stupid but
it's like all these streamers that are
blowing up right now and all these
people that are watching him it's like
it's call Crush TV right yeah like
you're just literally waiting for them
to do something stupid to just Hop On
Hop on the trend of hating them yeah
clip that up post it boom and what do
you make of the new generation like cuz
you're now kind of a few years on and
you're seeing uh speed and KET what do
you make of those guys I think live
streaming is super talented like I think
you to be a big live streamer is super
impressive cuz you have to be on
24/7 like it's not like a YouTube video
where you can just have the entertaining
Parts cut it up like when you're not dry
you have to have that energy for hours
and hours at a time so like I respect
them I used to live stream so it's like
I know what it's like to it kind of just
makes you go insane so like Kai
and and speed and like all those dudes
like respect them and like I'm
surprised you guys haven't went insane
yet yeah and you see Kai senet being
like live streaming Drake's album and
Drake touching Drake's making songs
about it mental and going back
to the Austin thing I mentioned him
before will you ever fight Austin MC
Brom again so this is so funny Austin
McBroom uh wanted to fight me again kind
of says a lot uh what what does it to I
mean it's just like he already beat me
why does he why does he want to fight me
again right um loses to Gib twice can we
stop on that cuz I wanted to know what
is it like when a guy who who beat you
and it was quite Bad Blood it was like a
very one-sided fight but then you see
him get the dog beaten out of him
by Gibb did you take any pleasure in
that or did you feel a certain way like
oh it's your turn now or I didn't think
Gibb I didn't think Gibb was going to
win that so like first off respect to
Gib for making him making him look like
absolute light work uh it kind of made
me realize like like it kind of
made me feel like cuz I'm like wow
the guy that beat my ass just got his
ass beat oh really yeah I'm like
wow that's cuz you so you were kind of
rooting like all right well you beat me
I hope you're doing good yeah it's like
I hope you keep doing well CU It'll like
say like okay there's the level Gap but
it's like got his ass kicked uh Austin
McBroom is he needs money right now um
how' you know that lawsuits he's
moving to smaller and smaller houses oh
really what's lawsuits about you know
there were about like a loan on his on
his previous house combined two
houses uh lots of scams that that
they've been doing that that family and
uh scammed the fighters on all my card
like on on our fight card like he's like
a scam guy like he's a scumbag
so there's real like you dislike this
guy I mean it's like I'll shake his hand
but I do not respect what he's done for
for his time being on social media he's
not a respectable guy um I would love to
fight him again because I'm not the same
person at all and I I I guarantee the
the result would be him face planted on
the ground um and I know I said this
last time but I I guarantee he would be
uh he would be knocked out like lifeless
knocked out because Gibb put him on his
I hit harder than Gibb I know I
know that for a fact um but he's
fighting G Perez the guy that I just
beat in be knuckle in be knuckle
don't know the date exactly yet it's not
like 100% official but he needs the
money be knuckle has money they're gonna
pay him and if if he wins against G
Perez which I don't think is gonna
happen because he has no Chin we rematch
bare knuckle wow that would be sick
Austin I I really like I really hope you
know because I know you're going to see
this clip bear knuckle's different it's
different if you couldn't take a punch
with a glove it is different without a
glove and if you get through G Perez I
hit hard like bear knuckle you are right
obviously bare knuckle is hard and it
ain't going to be the same as the Gib
fight with with the gloves on it is
different game completely and and you
know you're allowed to pull the chin and
give them a few SL on yeah yeah
you found that one out uh and and I'll
completely agree with you on on one
thing you are a different figh it would
be different if if nothing else you are
a way harder fight now than what you
were then way harder so and I think the
excitement would be there for that fight
just because we two influencers who one
has gone away and leveled up and grown
and and now is a different fighter and
the other guy who won has now had a
couple of losses looks much more human
and then you're adding the bare knuckle
element into it this is a long running
Feud this would do money for sure it
would be a great fight yeah like so if
he if he does win against J Perez uh
that's that's his money fight that's the
fight that could that would would pay
pay the bills yeah nor B be coming yeah
I think he he needs this G Perez fight
because it's it's a money fight as well
it's sad for me to hear an influencer
who's done so much with his career who's
earned so much money and was in that big
ass H huge mansion now in a situation
where he scammed people and he's
it up and now he's doing smaller houses
and like money management and stuff
ain't included in the influencer uh
handbook so to speak yeah I mean like
it's just it's karma yeah yeah and like
it'll come back he never he never like
bought a
house like with all the money that he
scammed and like could have he could
have bought a house at least it
was all rented basically everything was
rented yeah his cars his actually I
think his cars were bought his cars were
bought so he had to sell those that's
such a guy thing I'll rent the house buy
the car rent rent rent the house and he
rents like these multiple like these
these houses that he was renting they
weren't cheap rent like like he could
have bought a house he could he could
have put down a fat payment on a house
that size but he's renting these houses
for like 57 50 to 70k a month gez just
to rent to rent a
house like just to look like to the
public like yo look how rich I am no and
then it's like it the house has just
kept getting smaller and smaller and now
he lives in like a really he lives in
like North Hollywood which if you guys
know where that is like in California
it's like a really bad area well not a
really bad area just like shout out
North Hollywood yeah shout out North
Hollywood it's not like like it's not
Beverly Hills right yeah ain't what he
used to have basically that is that
is wild yeah but hey you can Austin
you can buy that house you can buy like
a new house with the money that you'll
get for fighting GS and then if you win
you can fight me and that's another
money fight H that's sick hm that's like
a good that's a good plan for you so
like train hard for this bare knuckle
so let's say you beat deji you beat
um you beat Austin
McBroom who's your goal fight like who's
the guy who you're like that's my main
event and that's the peak of the
mountain for me K I yeah yeah and then
it's
like then like what though it's like
sizewise you're quite a good match quite
similar bill I think I think he's uh
he's 170 right like he fights at 170 I'd
say he's a natural yeah he could get to
170 I think he could go even later I
think he could go 165 actually if you
really that's what I usually like we
fight at
55 I I could go lighter but it's just
hell that's why it's it's crazy for me
that he's fighting 183 Tommy Fury when
you know like the Wasabi fight he was in
camp at 174 and I'm like well you could
easily sweat n pounds off and you're
eating up to fight Tommy like and
Tommy's cutting right down to 183 and
going right back up to what 200 or
something you know what I mean yeah I
dude I I was uh I I went was 195 when I
signed the G Perez contract if iight at
165 weighed in and then the next day I
was like 180 there you go yeah so Tommy
will be 200 the night after the
rehydration is is ridiculous like that
that will make you fill up like that's
why everyone was saying I look so much
bigger than him the the day of the fight
but if you look at our weighin photo and
our weigh-in videos we look the same
exact size like I gained 15 PBS
overnight and now you've got
experience of doing that you know what
was that W cut like what did yeah it was
like 900 calories a day two two um two
intense cardio sessions every single day
um and I was 25 lbs over a week and a
half before my weighin wow so I cut that
20 lb in a in like that is that's
probably a lot right that's probably too
much yeah it was like mainly water it's
like I I did like saa's like crazy the
last few days um but yeah no I'm I'm
right back up I'm like 190 right now I'm
like and final question is how would you
like to be remembered biggest
balls like I that that kid has
balls uh he's not afraid to do anything
I think that's great you know like in in
in the Pro fighting game you look at the
Nate Diaz's people like him people don't
give a if he wins or Los his record
was not that great yeah they don't care
we just want to see you scrap cuz you
are here to scrap and we appreciate that
and I think if you go down that road in
fighting it won't matter especially cuz
let's be real you're a bit of a pretty
boy so people weren't expecting that
from you especially be knuckle so that's
why I think everyone was like well
done you know what I mean yeah
yeah dude the people here in UK like a
lot of the the fans are showing support
out here like of the bare knuckle fight
they don't even like know me off of Tik
Tok yeah because your bare knuckle fight
did 6 million views or something
yeah 12 million concurrence and and they
were that like there's people coming up
they're like yo you're the the bare bare
knuckle guy like you're the fist guy and
I was like the Fister that's that's what
I'm known as the Fister no dude
genuinely I think you'll get M love in
um in Manchester when there yeah I'm
excited for for the prime fights I'm
going to be there yeah and I want to see
what like the audience is going to be
like there cuz I think I'm going to
fight here against deji wow yeah that
would I I would want to fight in in the
UK I think that's a great idea because
the the audiences over here and I'm sure
you're going to find this out are crazy
and deji will get mad love and yeah
you'll be the bad guy but you're cool
with that you're you're built for it for
sure I walked out to G Perez getting
booed that that was kind of
fun yeah you handled it well right yeah
I've seen you like you see no you see me
in the in the walk out I'm like
I was like all my nerves I was just
trying to get them all out I was like
all right here we go here we yeah
yeah man I can't wait man you've been a
great guest thank you very much
appreciate you for having me yeah big
love it's Bryce Hall true Johnny podcast
we can catch him soon fighting deji
can't wait for it
[Music]
cheers